Fiat's off-road testing facility and by
local Italy has been out of reach for
the cinquecento until the latest model
came out Montes says this isn't just any
Fiat 500 but a Fiat Cinquecento ex the
crossover version of the little Italian
car and it can handle moderate terrain
but that's only if you've got the all
wheel drive version or at least the
front wheel drive equipped with the
traction plus system all the versions
have ground clearance of nearly 18
centimeters and generous approach and
departure angles but Fiat knows most of
its buyers are more impressed with an
off-road looks rather than actual
off-road driving so there's also a more
toned down version for town driving
Montes says he actually likes the more
rugged 500 X with its pugnacious front
bumper much more than the 500 X that's
been dressed up for city driving and
it's back on the road in the rugged 500
X it can handle the bumps of off-road
driving and still look stylish a special
feature of the new all-wheel-drive is
automatic decoupling of the rear axle
for fuel efficiency when traction from
all four wheels isn't necessary and no
torque is being applied the color
automatically switches to energy-saving
two-wheel drive
about new just because you can go
off-road doesn't necessarily mean you
have to the all-wheel drive can be
advantageous on the road to the mood
selector can be used to select the
driving mode that best fits weather
conditions or how the driver feels the
all-wheel-drive system automatically
decides how much power is distributed to
each wheel
Mantha says the steering is unexpectedly
stiff for a crossover he's pleased it's
more like a sporty compact he adds that
the steering wheel could be a bit more
elegant but it'll Lou I was fine how
about boys as its unmistakeably a
sibling of the little [ __ ] each a big
wide eyed headlights just as they are on
the familiar Fiat 500 make that clear as
do the radiator chrome and the badging
the protective skirting running from
front to back stands out and a gently
sloping rear window gives it a more
dynamic look than the 500l
the interior is more an evolution and
design than a revolution the dashboards
confidently simple and competently
crafted the seats have the typical round
headrests but they're a bit deeper and
there's plenty of space in the back the
model we drove here starts at 28,000 650
euros Fiat rates fuel consumption at 5.5
liters per 100 kilometers and the engine
at 103 kilowatts of power a 9 speed
automatic transmission handle shifting
flawlessly the 500x is on offer in 100
countries it's built at the Fiat plant
and Melfi Italy
my father Montes sums up saying that
with the 500x the Fiat has finally made
a car for adults with an adventurous kid
inside the small two-door chinco Kento
is a bit too delicate and likely suited
only to city driving and the 500l isn't
quite as stylish different from that in
Finnish and from here sheekha yeah Fiat
prices have long been high enough to
debunk the illusion that the Cinque
ochenta will get the masses on the road
for less Monta says the no-frills base
price of 17,000 euros can rapidly double
to mount up to a pretty penny but he
adds that the cars well made and really
doesn't have many flaws about it or skip
diagonally sun's finally critic Poulter
it's a small car that can look forward
to many big adventures
you